damn you can stay open with the sea not
New York baby even out here dude there's
a couple seed restaurants
um but C is for clean
Clorox only
C is passing
[Music]
there was a New York City Korea Town
restaurant that was shut down after very
interesting menu option what I'll say it
dog everyone say it come on let's
everyone on the count of three
just pick your stereotypical animal it's
either dog or now they're having an
issue with live octopus okay so that's
your guess what's your guess you said
Koreatown dog New York City Koreatown
New York City Korea time oh New York oh
never mind rats rats
that's a good guess cannoli a bad
cannoli bro rats it's rats do
that's dude rats yeah but aren't the
rats massive out there
ever seen have you ever heard of the Rat
King yeah from Ninja Turtles no no
that's Splinter wait there's a rat king
too from the from the sewer she's a
villain will you talk don't Gaslight me
you got sliding me childhood is he in
the second one or the first he's a white
guy he's in the cartoon yeah
covered in bandages
free range called rat dude so have you
ever
you heard the [__] yeah dude I'm from
New York bro oh yeah so what's the Rat
King is like all the rats in the subway
can't uh
they can't move because it's dark so all
their tails intertwine and then they
start fusing together oh so then they
have to move as like one unit and if
they don't they die because they can't
escape and now obviously there's like
urban legends of this massive right
right like this rat the Terminator it's
kind of tight but they know this because
they can find skeletons
well now that we're up to speed on the
Rat King uh no so there's a couple right
there ordering from this restaurant in
Koreatown
they want spicy beef soup dish
and when they get it the um the um
there's a rat tail dangling dead rat or
in the middle of it oh but is it is it
like what they intended or was it no no
they intended not when they intended oh
so the the rat got in the soup wait who
brought it out they didn't see a big rat
in the soup oh I saw this let me see can
I see oh dude you can't hide that bro
that's gross I don't know what I'm
looking at that is a full it's a full
it's just it's like cooked I mean rats
getting into soup is kind of a global
problem it is you know that happens but
not in America dude dude Ratatouille
failed man I know
you're supposed to rain again
that should be [__] illegal yeah now
happened to Jason Cheney's soup remember
when he was at that Military Academy who
wants Burgers maybe the food is really
good yeah this might be worth it I mean
it went in there because obviously
trying to eat and then it was like [__]
it's hot I'm done it was apparently so
not good that not even eating it it left
the couple disgusted violently sick
causing them to vomit and seek medical
attention they also claimed to suffer
from severe serious permanent injuries
and accused the business of negligent
infliction of emotional sounds like some
New York Sue [__] yeah I'm gonna say
what were their permanent injuries I get
being like ah [__] there's a rat in our
soup this is [__] up emotional Man by
the way as of Thursday afternoon this
place was called gam milk has a c rating
on the on that's it oh yeah it had a c
even prior to that oh it's pretty bad
though bad rap dude that's crazy a c
means like not only do you got rats you
got snakes you got bats you got
everything so cause like you can get a B
if you're like your manager isn't there
when the health inspector comes but if
there's a c that means the manager isn't
watching that's gross failure to protect
food from potential source of
contamination the presence of Filth
flies or food yeah use sewage associated
with frsa files or flies flies I always
thought when you got to see that you
were you had to be forced to like close
and fix the problem I don't know damn
you could stay open with the sea not New
York baby even out here dude there's a
couple sea restaurants
um but C is for clean
Clorox only
oh dude that made my stomach hurt so so
what's this restaurant yeah how's
retaliated yes they say they reviewed
security footage couldn't find any
problems when we transferred the soup we
served it four times with a ladle while
the staff washed it with their eyes if
there was a mouse that big there's no
way we would have missed it oh so they
threw it in there
the plot thickens so does the soup they
say that this person ordered food with
ubereats and if a rat came out it could
be argued as evidence saying look at
this when they came to our store but we
didn't see anything so how can we know
that you guys didn't put the rat in
there and now you're claiming emotional
distress and all this [__] all this
legalese that they're using to set up a
lawsuit potentially wait oh so it's
ubereats they had it at home yeah
oh [__]
I thought it sounds a little
to me sounds a little fishy
a little bit apparently the um the
restaurant also did a little bit of
digging about this particular couple and
they found out that they're [__] oh
they did the Chili's thing they're just
[__]
because I'll be good if they they had a
string of lawsuits against restaurants
that had rats they maybe they were the
Wendy's people right didn't someone find
us a finger and a Wendy salad not too
long ago oh recently it was like 20
years ago I remember that was two weeks
ago it was like 20 weeks ago really yeah
you wouldn't like find a mouse or a
finger it was a finger finger one was
like 20 years ago that was the chili
that was like the the store maybe a
jack-in-the-box almost completely get
taken out because of mad cow disease or
some [__] with the burgers but that's
different that's just that's a protein
and it was real that was real too
because I didn't grow up eating Jack in
the Box none of us did and I but I
remember the commercials and stuff until
later on past high school they came back
because then they had Jack as a mascot
they didn't have that growing up yeah
that was their way of repairing the
damage from the Mad Cow making Jack a
stoner but have you seen any any Jack in
the Box stores back then I don't
remember yeah we had one in Downey right
by my house but we weren't eating it
because my parents told me that you'll
die from eating the burger I didn't hear
any of that because people straight up
died bro dude Chipotle had a similar
thing but with it was called the lettuce
lettuce yeah oh yeah serious I was a I
was thinking about being a shareholder
back then so I was like oh God I stayed
away from that one one of my one of my
friends got the sick from Chipotle I had
to go to the hospital
they ran all the tests and then finally
they were like holy [__] you got E coli
from Chipotle oh my God and he's like
was he able to like get any money I
don't I don't think so damn really I
don't I just don't think he liked it I
don't think he cared so he was like I'm
out of the hospital the restaurant went
on to claim that the couple had also
bitched about flies on another Yelp
review at another restaurant in
Koreatown and
um also they have been accused of trying
to bribe their way out of this like they
offered a couple five grand as what has
leaked out but the restaurant says we
never offered them five grand wow I hate
Korean restaurants or what I actually
kind of believe that I don't feel like
Asian restaurants would bribe you to
yeah that's weird I feel like that
wouldn't happen Oh They'll bite you to
death you ordered the wrong [__] [__]
yeah yeah yeah this is your fault you'll
be like you pay us five thousand dollars
but we don't we don't know what's true
yet though right I could see like a very
rich restaurant wanting to bribe you
nothing on the record but if they
already have a c dude you can't threaten
Asian restaurants with like bad reviews
no they'll be like so well have you seen
the someone online I saw it was perfect
a three and a half star review for Asian
restaurants is the golden Zone because
they're like the food is excellent the
service sucks ah no the food is always
gonna rock because all of these people
go and it gets a three and a half
because the service is zero but the food
is five yeah that makes sense but could
you go to Five Star plays it's like oh
the service is good but you know the
food is okay and I'm like well what the
[__] are you doing food box is all you
should buy like listen if you go in
there I would say it's about Indian
restaurant if you go in there and the
waiter gives you 45 minutes to eat and
say get the [__] out that means food's
good yeah because they have high
turnovers they're like get the [__] out
hurry up I got more they need to move
that yeah stop having conversations yes
go to the Boba shop next door I like it
I like the idea that when um it's like 8
30 at night and they want you to leave
so they start putting chairs upside down
around oh yeah but that's classic it's
like not close till 11. yeah
love is like when you as an Indian
person in an Indian restaurant when they
do [__] like that I'm like you do know
that I know these tricks right so I
don't give a [__] we're riding this
thing till closing time
11 o'clock I'm here till 1101. Health
Inspectors reportedly found droppings at
the restaurant oh
um the restaurant is currently closed
evidence
um there's a close sign in front of the
door uh the business also allegedly
failed to store food at the correct
temperature lack the train supervisor
and has been operating without proper
permits that's why I got it and nobody
knows can they check if it's uh it's one
of those pet rats or like you can buy
this rat or if it's a New York rat like
can you tell like DNA testing yeah
they're gonna do a 23andMe on the rack
if it has a caller then you know it
would be pretty good evidence if they
found that it was caught from some other
trap method and then it had like visible
adhesive you know from like a wrap I
don't think they did an autopsy on the
rat was it yeah does it actually have
the uh Korean soup they've drowned in a
Korean soup oh yeah or yeah was it
killed some so here's the real was it
seasoned if it was seasoned it if it
wasn't seasoned these [__] yeah
you gotta taste the rat they planted it
they planted the wrap you know if it's
an ingredient it's seasoned it's hard to
think that they would miss that though
it's just so [__] big but yeah and if
they're doing a ladle yeah like has the
skin on mm-hmm it's a full right what
did this The Furs come off if it was the
whole pot would be [__] up they don't
understand this I think it was planted I
think it's planted because if it was
really in the soup all day that's braise
baby it's braised it would be tender it
would be but we don't know that it's not
braids we just saw a picture of it and
we're just no but to that point the
first should be coming off like Chicago
used to do chickens what kind of Stew is
it this is
kimchi kimchi Stu it was red but when
you put like a whole thing in like a
whole chicken or whatever and you boil
it long enough it it breaks breaks apart
yeah with the slightest touch it falls
apart and rats they're they're pretty
you know they're weak they could break
apart they could break apart
this guy's braised a rat before
we need a slow boil a rat and see and
like also do they use an instapot that
might increase the time it is true
though that when you're working in a
restaurant and everything's like motor
skill like you kind of it's automatic
like I could see someone missing a rat
you would have felt you care about your
business it's pretty heavy so put it in
a plastic container you put a [__]
yeah that's the thing it's going in it's
going into a to-go container I guess if
they have a large vat of whatever
they're making it's in there but you're
like it doesn't fit the ladle yeah it
doesn't go clean bro the biggest ladles
are like this all it takes is one
employee that really doesn't give a [__]
that's true you know but if they gotta
see they probably don't have money to
hire other employees it's probably a mom
and pop shop or maybe it's their [__]
ass son that doesn't care
the classic mistake yeah dude I mean
don't hire your family I don't know
maybe you just have to look at the rate
of like how often are these things ended
up being fake versus when they're really
especially also what are the complaints
on the restaurant themselves if this is
the first time of some massive incident
yeah High chance it's a little too
spot-on for a New York restaurant to
have a whole rat in there like because
you would expect it to happen more often
right right it's too stereotypical like
if you were expecting rat to come into
food it's coming from a New York City
restaurant because there's rats
everywhere yeah but like that's City
living but it's almost like it's it's
almost even worse that it would happen
because you live in a place where you
should expect maybe there might be a rat
around so you'd be more conscious about
it maybe more conscious it would have
been better if it was a pigeon because
you could eat it oh yeah you're right
yeah you're right
[Music]
foreign